[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si vous attrapez dans ce meeting hier
sous toutes les similitudes entre eric
zemmour et nicolas sarkozy en 2012 même
lui même meeting quasiment même façon de
faire au garde des sceaux me
vous êtes 200 milles
j'ai choisi le trocadéro en pensant au
général de gaulle qui fit ici sur cette
place voilà comment parler le général de
gaulle et comment nous parlons
aujourd'hui sur la place du trocadéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
alors c'est vrai quelle raison ces accès
c'est ça ça soit on a tous pensé à ça
hier quand on a vu les images et on va
revenir sur ce qu'il a dit hier eric
zemmour pour la première fois il a parlé
de l'islam sympa pour l'apprendre fois
que la police amène autrement il a voulu
s'adresser directement aux musulmans ils
l'assurent il n'est pas raciste regarde
je veux parler directement à nos
compatriotes de confession musulmane car
les journalistes et les politiciens vous
désinforme et vous mentent ils vous font
croire que je veux vous empêcher de
pratiquer votre religion c'est faux vous
êtes issu d'une culture que je connais
bien car mes parents mes grands parents
sont nés en algérie que vous le dis il y
a un problème avec l'expansion de
l'islam aujourd'hui en france et je ne
parle absolument pas d'abandonner la
pratique de votre religion rien ne vous
empêche d'être très français et de vie
botton religion dans le respect des lois
et dans la discrétion
alors je vous montre un double pour ceux
qui n'ont pas vu aller les grandes
extrait i là pour appuyer son
argumentaire eric zemmour a rappelé
qu'il était je cite injuste berbère
regarde je suis venu au trocadéro pour
remercier la france ce pays qui m'a tout
donné qui a accueilli ma famille qui m'a
offert sa culture oui ce pays qui a
permis aux petits juifs berbères que je
suis de me retrouver sur l'une des plus
belles places du monde devant vous
aujourd'hui
quelles émotions me submerge en vous
regardant comment comment ne pas penser
à mes parents j'espère du fond du coeur
qu'ils sont fiers de moi delahousse
et enfin le dernier extrait d'eric
zemmour a duré alors cessé d'être durs
et outranciers là il s'est lâché à la
fin il faisait - olivier bédard là il
avait pris du lit et 8 tablettes de
l'iso pays à la fin c'était parti
regardez la fin du discours garde rien
ni personne ne nous empêchera décrire le
destin de notre pays parce qu'il
faudrait nous arracher le coeur et ils
n'y arriveront pas parce que le pote qui
décide de se lever
surprise de cette campagne
est indépendante
qui ne baisse jamais les cieux
de l'effort et du mérite
puissance française
conquête c'est l'eau vive la paix et la
fraternité
vive la prospérité et la dignité vive la
vérité vive la république et surtout sur
l'eau
[Applaudissements]
alors olivier medard vous êtes
l'organisateur de ce meeting ça coûte
s'il ya des moyens colossaux c'est pas
les prag douanes una sur ses 8 ans a
commencé après minuit non là on est sur
près de 500 mille euros pour la partie
technique le son la lumière la
décoration il a fallu couvrir une
palissade assez immonde derrière ce
qu'ils n'avaient pas sarko il y avait un
parfum purr d'où on a dû faire des
choses un peu plus compliqué près de
cinq cent mille euros pour l'ensemble de
l'opération plus jaillir les à-côtés
tiers l'écart
on est on est sur un million tourne
autour d'un million d'euros pour une
manifestation comme ça oui alors laurent
fontaine sans parler politique parce que
voilà c'est vrai que voilà est ce que si
les meetings et réussie pour vous tant
que oui oui oui c'est un bon point qu'on
peut mettre aux équipes d'olivier
d'ailleurs commence par une gentillesse
ils sont bien organisés ils vont
organiser la bar mitzvah non fissile ans
non mais franchement moi j'ai juste
meeting devant le discours était bien
écrit enfin pas exactement ça vous
emmerde et pax en
regard des failles que ça vous emmerde
et pâtisseries non discours bien écrit
il a été plutôt engageant il tient bien
lever la foule contrairement à d'autres
candidats médaillés sont dispo en quinze
jours d'écriture de travail j'imagine
c'est important j'imagine et surtout une
fin malines ont parlé de bavaria de
seconde avec la musique de sous quand il
fait c'est vous c'est vous qui est une
jolie feinte voilà bravo si c'est une
idée chaque éolienne bien la musique
l'objet en tout cas est réussi pour oui
oui mais c'est un métier où d'autres cas
quoi on avait déjà vu avec sarko et
fillon s'attend à perdre oui
la différence ses chansons mais on avait
vraiment envie de verser à
20h sur son mètre carré et d'autre part
de l'échangé suivez moi c'est stéphane
battle
afro k soit soit sociale échec ce nom
pas détenir du fce trop cassé hugo
lloris était battu chez le même veine
comme sarko était candidat à sa
réélection eric zemmour est là depuis
quatre mois quatre mois françois fillon
françois fillon ça fait 20 ans que je
fais de la politique marianne ça fait
100 106 raison qu'elles prennent des
coups sans vie de personne c'est
exceptionnel c'est un fait politique
exceptionnel et on peut pas nier sa non
non mais bon on va pas que matrix va
être sur les chiffres croco à trois
roues au métier ce que vous dites et
puis voilà cent mille c'est un faisable
sur la place du trocadéro
tous ceux qui nous regardent ce soir
mais c'est pas compliqué c'est moi qui
disparaît voilà fait pas comme candidat
laissez moi une phrase regarder les
images ben voyons est ce que je veux
dire c'est que
personne dans cette salle justement
c'est bon c'est pas possible et sans lui
c'est possible mais c'est pas possible
non pas lui vous le savez très bien on
n'était
jamais c'est dur disponible pour les
manifs vous avez ou mes tweets et
quelques jours en disant il y en a marre
des candidats qui subit pas sur les
chips les pilotes sont les chiliens ont
fait choisir sa veste et son plein peu
importe peu importe le vrai truc c'est
surtout pourquoi trocadéro ça qui est
intéressant au delà du fait qu
effectivement c'est un lieu qui porte
pas chance hein c'est la poisse mais ça
vous le saurez dans quinze jours le
deuxième point celle que je voulais bien
faire il fallait vous connaissez le vote
des gens vont vous ne connaissez pas la
puissance du secret de l'isoloir vous
avez raison vous faites une très bonne
très bonne un très bon lien parce que
c'est ça que vous allez chercher
dimanche en fait vous allez chercher les
abstentionnistes
vous allez cherchez pas ce qu'ils sont
des vins croix n'a pas cherché ces
laissez moi finir de parler et que vous
le faites au trocadéro dans cette
ambiance là avec ce décorum là parce que
vous savez comme si on avait fait comme
ça qu a voulu faire que des drapeaux
blancs lac tour eiffel derrière ça va
donner une ampleur et surtout un oui
discours de zemmour je le dise qu il
était intéressant pas une ligne de
programme pas une annonce pas un chiffre
uniquement de l'incantation c'est là
uniquement de dire des choses
l'incantation devait faire quoi pour
parler de la france pour parler mais
c'est bien ça le sujet avaient péri au
président et il va nous tomber sur la
tête pour faire voter les absents dit
c'est votre job est là et olivier que je
voulais dire un florent non mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que je suis absent
batman là vous vous êtes en éléments de
langage tu prenais à les gérer c'est le
travail si les seuls à parler le roi et
je vois et coutumes sa préhistoire sens
que je vais dire ce soir jeudi
régulièrement ici tout le monde sait
mais engagement à bien faire après les
rayons je travaille auprès d'un candidat
élections que j'en chiale
qu'il a 4 mois qu'il ya quatre mois
n'était pas candidat action résidentiel
bien joué en trois mois cent vingt mille
adhérents dans un parti c'est le premier
parti politique de france aujourd'hui
c'est pas déclic a comme vous faites
cesser d adhérents plan rappelle que
laurent fontaine et partisans d'un
soutien à la nouvelle macro là moi je
pense que jacques a déjà envoyé depuis
qu'il était que
le jeu de la démocratie mais il fait des
meetings il va ou terra eco kottak votre
candidat il fait des vidéos dont il est
candidat depuis quinze jours mais il est
inapte à faire litige d'excusés mois
maintenant on sait justement justement
je vous dit tellement de choses qui sont
fausses toutes les trois secondes avec
des bugs et ça prendrait deux heures il
fait toutes les semaines environ 3
sélections qu'il est quand même la
mythique sait pas forcément mais ça
c'est le père c'est un président eric
zemmour ça fait 80 meeting suisse est en
fait j'aimerais qu'on parle du sujet
voilà l'autre sujet c'est la foule qui
s'est mise à crier un moment macron
assassin place du trocadéro pendant le
discours du candidat eric zemmour
regardez je vous propose de revoir cette
fameuse séquence voilà regarde ou penser
que c'est vous qui devez avoir honte
mais non c'est l'état qui devrait à
boire autre
alors est-ce qu'ils aient entendu ça ou
pop n'ont
fait
une prise de parole devant cent mille
personnes en extérieur alors bien sûr
que
d'admettre des auteurs jugent d'ailleurs
moi je vais demander ce qu'il a entendu
et moi j'ai moi j'étais important se ne
l'ait pas entendu ça revenait d'une
partie je vous rappelle qu'on a sonorisé
l'ensemble de la place pour justement
entendre les clameurs la fin alors c'est
ça qui intéresse à partir de l'extrême
droite qui était qui était présente et
bien présente
vous me permet ainsi on parle de
souffrir ça à quel moment on à quel
moment le public l'a réagit un zemmour
ne l'entend pas 2 quand on lui dit il
dit je ne soutiens pas ce moment je ne
soutiens pas ce mot je ne cautionne pas
tout de suite immédiatement en même
temps ça il dit il vous avait lui dit je
ne peux pas maîtriser s'ennuie personnel
moment un homme qui buvait tisser lagon
sera quel moment le public réagit au
moment où il parle des victimes
réagissent parce que macro assassins
c'est au fond est victime cieux
justement les victimes du terrorisme et
la sunna mist voulez mais par exemple
être victime au bataclan pardon mais
excusez moi macron n'était pas oui la
belle image sur oloron non mais au fond
ils dénoncent le public dénonce quoi le
laxisme le laisser faire
la la la la la pseudo c'est ça qui
dénonce le public c'est une réaction
donc vous cautionnez ce que je dis
simplement éliminé public réagit c'est
plus que réagi parce qu'il en a marre qu
au fond on excuse on explique et une
partie du public pense à le sujet à
savoir c'est pourquoi le public 10,1 non
mais pas le but
la réponse du chef de l'état d' emmanuel
macron parce que eric zemmour a dit
qu'il n'en ai pas entendu regarder sa
réponse il a réagi à ça il ya deux
hypothèses la première félin dignité
plus tôt
une forme la plus crédible
ce n'est pas une surprise la deuxième
c'est la méconnaissance d'une réforme
très importante du quinquennat c'est le
100% santé et maintenant les prothèses
auditives les lunettes et des prothèses
dentaires sont remboursés par la
sécurité sociale 10 millions de
françaises et français ont eu accès à
cela ça fait partie de mon bilan c'est
un bilan social dont je suis fier et
bien vite alors à ce moment là le
candidat malentendants à pouvoir
s'équiper à moindre coût
oui la crise beaucoup de mépris dans
cette réponse
beaucoup d'ironie
c'était une réponse drôle mais peu se
l'appliqué à lui-même parce qu'il n'a
pas entendu ni les gilet jaune et toute
la colère
deuxième chose vous avez quand même les
dames ya scission les indignations à
géométrie variable parce que quand il
dit qu'il veut emmerder une partie de sa
population qui a des tribunes qui
circulent qui disent qu'ils appellent à
ne pas réanimer des gens non vaccinés la
civic et comme tout mais voyez poutine
anti bac
j'ai même réussi c'est que moi je suis
pas et maurice du tout non en tant que
site non pas du tout je suis parle en
tant que citoyenne par contre je n'ai vu
je ne vous ai pas vu laurent vous
insurgez camp quand antoine château le
chantre de brigitte macron appelé la
mort de l'eczéma ou avec un tweet
espérant à crash de l'avion dans lequel
était je n'ai pas vu l'indignation mais
on n'est pas
les équipes eric zemmour est
plus fort que ça les landes intelligente
et belle tu parles
lelong malaisie - la très gentille
gentiment et intelligemment dit hier
dans son discours il est en fait on est
plus fort sur le net on est plus forte
en digital et c'est vrai et c'est drôle
parce que tous les arguments nous
chanter ce soir c'est les arguments que
vos équipes digital dès ce matin ont
commencé à relayer
rien pas laissez moi finir je passe tous
les trolls que je vais avoir
certainement sur leur compte dès demain
matin en mode ordures etc vous êtes
habitué à ça c'est comme ça que vous
fonctionnez avec des insultes avec des
mots forts
désaccords je leur ai bien que zemmour
se fait arrêter de larmes de nazis à la
ronde et ce n'est jamais par email à 10
ans
ici jamais commenté rouge vert et et de
juste servi car j'adore la prison s'ils
jettent des torts en raison
des caricatures la voyez la caricature à
l'ema au
delà des petites au delà donc de la
caisse ce soir plus profondément
derrière quoi il ya un vrai public qui
vote zemmour et qui d'un public de facho
soyons clairs donc si tu lui
sinon c'est des gens qui sont réac
saison son bail avec sensé des jo devant
lui il y avait
eu ces français qui ont ras-le-bol de
voir ce qui se passe il y avait des gens
qui votent et fillon qui veut dire sarko
des abstentionnistes de gens de toutes
les générations y avait cette frange
haute en train d'insulter à baisser les
lumières en france et insulter quelqu'un
continue
il ya des gens il ya des gens qu'on peut
et françois plus la france ait des gens
qui ont peur et étrangers avaient alors
c'est grave c'est vers des gens
pillaient des gens qui ne le dos qu'on
est facho il ya des gens qui n'aimaient
pas les allemands caricatural il ya des
gens qui n'aiment pas j'ai pas
l'impression il ya des gens qui n'aiment
pas les émissions de cyril hanouna et
qui pose c'est qui
alain dejean parmi ces gens là que cyril
détrompe-toi beaucoup de racisme
beaucoup d' antisémite beaucoup de mots
fob trois mois et sont en moi celanese
tout ce qui était là
qu'il est associé
solivellas en dehors du réel vous savez
quoi
yoplait sur ma croix ça ça olivier s'il
avait entendu eric zemmour il aurait il
aurait calmé la foule je vous assure que
quand on est la place et avec le vent
dans le dos on ne l'entend
jamais sûr qu'on l'entend
mais oui non comme j'étais plus souvent
micro que dwan un deuxième studio
si vous avez gardé la qualité c'est
quand en 2007 matin qu'en 2017
en 2017 mais la vérité c'est tabou du
coup il y avait des gens avec ça mérite
des gens qui sifflaient dans les
meetings j'ai été moi même à des
meetings notamment à lattes on a été au
dernier meeting va ensemble ces sept
jours avant l'élection présidentielle
des macros et ça à siffler ça siffle
parfois ces passionnés archives de ce
qu'a répondu un jour eh ben voilà on la
voyait ça va nous coûter un billet et
l'importante qu'elle continuer avec ces
règles on s'était habitué
non
mais s'il fallait pas jamais on ne se
rassemblent pas sur des cycles et
[Applaudissements]
encore une fois c'est un meeting indoor
à l'extérieur dans le sang à l'intérieur
quand on est à l'intérieur on entend
tout et effectivement quand on est à
l'extérieur et qu'on a le vent dans le
dos la clameur techniquement on ne
l'entend pas c'est un brouhaha total un
meeting extérieur s'est pas meeting
intérieur et ça c'est mon métier je peux
vous le dire et quand on est à deux
mètres de haut avec le vent dans le dos
on n'entend pas et ils entendaient pas
et je lui ai demandé il eric zemmour est
sincère toujours et je suis si leur vie
envie de dire macron assassin il aurait
écrit dans son lit alors tourner toutes
les deux ténors vous désapprouvez macro
assassin béatrice est évidemment
mesdames palombes notamment fermés
l'escadron trafic important celui là
c'est beaucoup mais voilà un film
ailleurs il rit tout de suite je ne
cautionne pas ce mot pourquoi philippe
de villiers là ne l'a pas condamné ce
mot alors je sais pas je fais pas
philippe deuxième mais il est quand même
soutien de ces mesdames on lui demande à
lui bon boulot maintenant voilà sur il a
d'ailleurs tout de suite il l'a dit il a
tout dit quand il lui a dit ça lui
n'avait pas entendu alors eric zemmour a
dit oui il a il a réagi l'année il a dit
que concernant son meeting
s'y trouve ça anecdotique
réduire tout le meeting alsa c'est vrai
que c'est pas très honnête oui mais pas
condamné du coup moi je trouve
incroyable que les médias ne parlent que
de ça
c'est leur part les laisser le plus
sinon que les médias compétents moutier
alors nous on allait souvent journée
nous a parlé tout il y avait accrédité à
villepinte sur les 620 500 journalistes
à crever les saluts nazis une
cinquantaine afin l'ont vu va mal on a
parlé beaucoup et c'est enfin tout le
monde a chanté une émotion une ferveur
juste incroyable danse un discours qui
était quand même très fort
dans les rédactions après c'est autre
chose ils ne font pas ce qu'ils veulent
et on a des sons de cloches éternel
willy rizzo rien sur leur boulot non
mais les journalistes qui suivent les
ratios ne peuvent pas couvrir juste
olivella olivet mais là ce que vous êtes
en train de dire moi
il paraît qu'ils avaient des
journalistes qui étaient là qui vous ont
dit aux offres c'était extraordinaire
oui et derrière ce que vous reprochez
c'est que derrière ils retiennent que ça
ben oui et donc qu'est-ce que vous aurez
les merlus face il ya ben je sais pas
l'honnêteté pourtant on n'a pas montré
l'ensemble des cent mille personnes à
l'unisson applaudir quand eric zemmour
de cette main tendue aux musulmans de
france là on n'a vu personne n'en fut
rien pour la chose il le dit alors on
dit tu la vôtre et le
monde dit non mais je parle ensemble et
mais a besoin on a tous regardé dit non
franchement la caricature qu'on fait de
cette opération est scandaleuse on
déjoue la presse joue un jeu très
dangereux et vous allez voir les
surprises que vous avez le 10 avril au
soir vous ferez peut-être un peu moins
de 2 de présomptions comme ça et c'est
plus de jeux suis pas prétentieux j'ai
pas lu je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de
mépris mais soit en jeu c'était people
bien des gens
et puis eric zemmour il parlera des
français qui en ont vraiment ras le bol
bah oui parce qu'on dit peter g c'est
même le but de mon deuil c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont ras-le-bol et c'est pour ça
qu'il les laisse exprimer les pires n
est pire que ben non moi je crois que
l'europe vraiment que vous vous traitez
ans quand on vend manif il ya énormément
de gens vous avez changé vous était tout
excité
il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
effectivement mécontents de la politique
des malouines leveaux qui en manif le
comment s'appelle macro assassin je l'
ai entendu à plusieurs et vu la
politique qu'il a menée ces dernières
années que ça soit les étudiants qui ont
rien à bouffer conviennent à bouffer les
soignants suspect
rien les candidats ont purgé près de la
fin c'est ce mécontentement
weddady kg il accepte
dernier mot je vous laisse le mot de la
fin sur basso sur hyères que si vous
dites non c'était un moment juste
incroyable j'ai re quelqu'un qui a 4
mois n'était pas candidat ait fait ça ça
croyez moi j'attends les politiques sur
le qui-vive royal macro je vous dis
rentrée sera au deuxième tour mais où de
roland garros
il sera au deuxième tour d'accord elle
savait que déclare candidat une
désignation qui oblige il faudra juste
qu'ils se si jamais il arrive au
deuxième tour on sera au deuxième
attendons attendons quelques jours on
verra à celle des bras si tu parleras
oui à qui se forme un peu et qui s'arme
un peu pour le débattement transformer
leurs sincères sur l'économie
lorsqu'il est jugement dit la vérité le
meeting il a envoyé quand même aux
livres d'éditeurs j'ai commencé en
disant ça je suis honnête c'est bien sûr
que ça met 500 1000 boul tu es j'attends
un mignon mignon un couloir
en diamant payés par les adhérents ah
oui les militants plaît